so
why run for governor why run for
governor well the big reason i'm running
for governor can you pull up his website
please
well thank you for that i am tired of
seeing what's happening in california
uh all my friends are leaving people are
getting squeezed out and it's because
we have a very oppressive regime of
the top guy at the top we'll go through
it trying to uh tell you how to live
your life and how to run your life taxes
are too high we're ranked 40th in
schools it's ridiculous we should be
ranked one in schools
in california with the money that we
collect uh and we get misled by our
leaders you know we get told we have a
surplus meanwhile we're going 12 billion
dollars in debt to forgive people's
traffic tickets
uh it's it's some of the things that are
going on some of the policies feel
really criminal
the voters of california legalized
cannabis in 2016
90 of cannabis businesses are still
struggling with provisional licenses to
even be
remotely legal and so most people still
sell it so kev
let me ask you so what does that do to
you said policies right
due to policies are those liberal
policies or
are those capitalistic you know
conservative policies well my big thing
is
i believe that uh the the first thing we
need is is a leader that focuses on
solving the real issues that we have and
there are there are four massive ones
housing schooling homelessness traffic
to me those are bipartisan priorities
can you say that one more time housing
homelessness
housing homelessness traffic schools
those are bipartisan priorities i don't
care if you're a republican i don't care
if you're a democrat
nobody wants to see homeless people
dying on the street we have more people
dying on the street to homelessness than
we do to gun violence in california
uh we've got uh uh we've got ridiculous
traffic we talked about schools already
and housing's unaffordable we know that
so people getting squeezed out on top of
that we tax
at some of the highest tax rates in the
country so uh it's it feels like
taxation without representation what
kind of a democrat are you
you you you're running as a democrat but
not a lot of your policies
seem like democratic policies like it
doesn't sound like a newsome policies it
doesn't sound like a
brown policy it it doesn't even sound
like an arnold policy some of your
policies are even a little bit further
right than
arnold's would be so how do you see
yourself as
a democrat i see them as californian
policies i think
uh what what are the problems that we
have yeah and then
how can we reasonably solve them and in
my opinion we have
incredible opportunities to stop wasting
money on things like the high speed rail
they're spending 125 million a mile on a
high-speed
rail that's going from from bakersfield
up to norcal
why they say it's for economic benefits
cato cato did a study on it they said
economically it's
break even at best over 70 years and
it'll take that long to be carbon
neutral
it's a waste of money well if you're
going to go that far go all the way say
why it's been it's costing that much
money who's who owns the land and who's
selling it well let's let's also be real
about this nancy pelosi
dianne feinstein gavin newsom yeah we'll
be honest it's public record hey you
know what else the public record is is
the
husband of dianne feinstein uh donated
or donates to gavin newsom's recall
campaign
and uh he is a contractor on the
high-speed rail is that
so there you go just google so i mean
you know if if we if you're going to use
you know
if you're going to use bipartisanship as
a talking point which i applaud you for
you have to be willing accountability is
the first part of bipartisanship
what you need is transparency you need a
youtuber in government so we can do
daily vlogs and show what it's really
like back there
how many how many shady contracts are
going out when you're making youtube
videos going
these are the options we got we got this
contract from tesla we got this one from
you know ford and we got this one for
this
what's the best one becomes a whole lot
easier to
stop uh seeing money go to shady places
when you're transparent about it
but the more and more regulation they
have the the more money gets funneled
into dark pools and dark ways of
spending
the more restrictions the more
california tries to enter your life the
shadier it actually so so let me go back
to the question brother
great job on deflecting three times
[Laughter]
fyi just so you know just so you know
here's what you need to know
let's hear it i am so glad you're
running oh thank you you have to know i
am so glad you're running i am so glad
you're running in a state that i lived
in for 24 years wow i'm glad a guy like
you was running well why'd you leave
let's let's go i will i'll tell you but
let's go back to it so let's go back to
it
so as a democrat everybody who
is a democrat or republican they have
somebody that they say
he was a good president i like the way
he did it who's your guy
look i think uh i'm a policy guy i look
at answers i'm not trying to deflect you
i look at policies
look i think there are great things that
obama did some things were great a lot
of things weren't great what did you
like what did you like about what
look there were some things that were
good that trump did too right and
there's some things that
trump did that weren't great i am so in
the middle i i don't
love identity i agree with you though
but i agree with you i don't see
then here's where i'm going with it i'm
going with
i think it's time but by the way i'm not
trying to corner you
i want to hear you say what you liked
obama i want to hear you say what you
liked about trump
but i think we're at a time uh where
there are people on the left who don't
uh
identify with today's left there are
people on the right that do not identify
with today's right
that's why we have manga with mega but
there are republicans that do not
identify with
mega there's a lot of people that don't
identify with mega i just thought you
know
maybe when i was looking i said okay
kevin's going to be running you did one
thing guys send me videos saying this
guy's running i said i would
love to see this guy run because what it
would do is
it would inspire you know how uh when
reagan ran
like hollywood remember the whole movie
michael j fox when they go all the way
back and says oh you know you know the
actor you know the b actor
he's gonna be a president he's like he's
gonna be president that guy's your
president no he's not the actor yes
but he opened it up for other people if
it's not reagan trump's probably not
running because trump's just kind of
like
well i'm going to go do it right i think
it's a time where we have a candidate
that runs
and shakes it up on the independent side
i don't think you're a democrat
i think you're independent wow by the
way i don't see you as a republican
either so i don't see you as a
republican
can i ask him like a follow-up yeah okay
you're you're a young smart strategic
guy i mean you're very successful you
get instant feedback
you know being a youtuber and everything
so you have a hand on the product okay
but listen
you have to be strategic if you're going
to do what you do you'd have no chance
to win if you came out as a republican
it was part of your strategy to become a
democrat or
run as a democrat because it would at
least get you in the door and maybe have
a shot
my belief is i'm so in the middle uh
that uh that that i've been a registered
democrat and to me i feel like i'm a
51-49
that's where i feel like i am so when
you're asking me for you know
specifically this president or this that
or whatever
it's so close it's so close but i'll
tell you this
and and this is not something i've
flip-flopped i've been registered since
i was 18.
uh as uh as a democrat in california i
understand
that california has a super majority of
democrats california
if a republican gets in california is
wasting the next year
because the next year on a republican
means democrats
just block it until the next election to
get a democrat which is the next
experience for the governor
so two follow-ups on that it's very very
interesting we did an interview with
ron paul and pat asked him straight up
you can actually watch the interview on
on valuetainment to ask him straight up
you're a libertarian you're not you're
not a republican why did you run as a
as a republican you remember what he
said he goes i wanted to win
you cannot say that he said i i would
have never won my county as as a
i would have never won but i tell you
one thing gerard here here's here's
where i go with that
uh i think uh today by the way even when
you're asking them questions you know
it's like well you know i like
obama's policies trump's policies what
is it oh you know it's just i can't find
i don't want to do identity identity
politics
people are scared today to run and just
kind of uh be locked in into a community
but here's where i go with you this is
where i go with you i'm i'm telling you
when i think about blue ocean strategy
take blue ocean strategy you know the
concept of blue ocean strategy the book
you know
increase decrease eliminate create right
increase decrease eliminate create
by the way take them in and grab
something yeah so
uh if there's ever been a time
go to the if there's ever been a time
you know the whole thing if there's ever
been a time where
you should buy gold today's the time if
there's ever been a time where
you should have no greater time that's
right right
if there's ever been a time where you
can
actually run in the middle with the
argument of
are you a rep like this be my campaign
are you on the right
but you don't fully identify with
everything people are saying on the
right
are you on the left and you fully don't
identify with everything that's been
said on the left for example if you're a
democrat you're some registered democrat
and you're a kennedy democrat maybe
you're a bill clinton democrat good
president right forget about what he did
not a communist he was he was a good not
a communist
but he was a good president right okay
maybe you relate with a bill clinton
democrat
right maybe you relate with a you know a
different kind of a republican not a
trump republican
time for in third party and let's go get
the independent ron paul got close
our buddy uh uh the texas uh what's his
name um
18 i think if there's ever been a time
to do that i think it's today so why
don't we do this before we get into
a little bit more can you pull up the
website to just go through some of these
policies
kai just pull up the website okay
where's the money in the middle come
from pat
uh from people like us i swear to god
people like us have money
there's people like us independents have
money you have to understand
independents are very
wealthy people don't realize how much
money is in the independent
camp independents are sitting saying
somebody have the balls to go run on
independent
let me come and be your flag carrier
i'll tell you i'm going to come and back
you up now
his position like the same reason why
trump didn't run on independent trump's
not a republican
no trump's never been a republican
trump's probably independent maybe he
sent or left the leaders
absolutely but he knew he had to do it
to kind of win so you kind of have to go
to a party
the state he's in can you imagine if he
ran as a republican that destroyed
discovery
you get no media coverage whatsoever i
mean well go ahead you were going to say
yeah
so here's the thing why do we have a
two-party system in this in in this
country it's because
when you want a campaign manager the
good ones are either on the democratic
party
or they're in the republican party
there's no good campaign manager
that's really trying to run a business
at some other party at least that i can
find anyone what's the patch the same
past points because there's no money
there
well maybe maybe that's exactly all the
money's funneling into the party funnels
and so that's where the jobs are and so
here's what happens
you know how hard it is to run a
campaign in california as a democrat
when if any democrat from california i
hire
is immediately branded as being
anti-newsome and being part of the
republican recall it's done
it's really hard i can see that that
person's entire career now
you supported a recall you know it's a
disaster how how aligned how
how party identified it is so that's why
i'm running on
fixed california i'm running on my big
five priorities we've got rallies coming
up this weekend and next weekend
and we've got a 20-point plan the top
five priorities are the ones we've been
talking about today
well let's do this folks if you got
questions send your questions on uh
twitter
at patrickbetdavid pbd podcast
hashtag pbd podcast we'll address some
of the questions but let's go through
your website okay
you have him into his website this is
his website meetkevin.com
so here's his plan you got plans in
fresno sacramento san bernardino
san diego is going all over the place go
yes on recall keep going up a little bit
california is beautiful
we've just lost our edge why yes on
recall false claim governor claim we
have 75.7 million dollars in surplus
california suggesting fact he's going
through numbers keep going lower because
on the bottom i think he's got what he
stands for keep going lower keep going
lower keep going lower
number one no homelessness in our
streets within 60 days that's number one
number two
massively reducing crime through new
community stop
policing and interrogate integrate in
integration with future schools number
three future schools
and two thousand dollars per month for
each attendee over 18 years old
interesting we'll come back to that one
making housing affordable okay keep
going uh
ending bad traffic and better roads that
also pay us
next no uh state income taxes on the
first 250 000
of income fully legalized gambling
fixing our immigration issues
no more blackouts no covet 2.0 lockdowns
lowering the cost of gas leading our
reunions nonprofit
agencies and business higher pay for
teachers firefighters and police
uh massive fire preventation prevention
effort that's big right there a lot of
people that's number 14 but that could
be big
for the people that are close to that
they're affected by that a lot ending
our water shortage big
big issue in california substantially
reducing gun violence
the underground handy person economy
energy and homes new net negative
communities
day one executive uh uh action and then
california transition bond so you got
all these into four
i want to vote for that that's what i
want i want that
that that is in california that works
that to me sounds like a republican or
an independent running okay
that that's what to me sounds like which
is by the way again
i get it i understand why uh but i think
you said you're a republican or
independent that means
you like it so much you want it to
identify with your side no i
i i don't i just i just understand look
uh so at this point everybody knows who
we sat with last week
okay everybody knows who we sat with
last week okay uh uh
on the mcafee video that i did yesterday
you know we had a full day with
giuliani last week at his place full day
a few hours of interview some of the
stuff he said let me just put it to you
this way
we put on youtube youtube's not going to
be happy we can't buy youtube right
and it's out of control to say the least
so now here's
the message that comes back the message
is hey you shouldn't be afraid of
freedom of speech you should put it up
there and all this other stuff
yeah okay youtube has the right to also
give you a strike and kind of mess up
with your platform all this other stuff
you know you know how that works out
because
when you're around you know i covered
trump rallies
as well as buying rallies they cover
both
biden rallies but that's fair uh but i
would cover them
i've literally had trump rallies that i
would just i would just cover from a
news pov hey let's see what
what is being said completely deleted
from my channel
just completely removed never had a
biden one removed
and youtube will just send me a
notification why do you think uh you
know they they use the incite violence
uh argument so they've gone through and
then oh well he said this
here so it's not like you're a pro-trump
guy you're not going up there saying
this guy's the greatest of all time
you're
kind of giving your comments there no
such thing as violence
so there's the energy the excitement i
don't know what it is but it's uh
yeah you you do see that uh so there is
and unfortunately
that as uh somebody who covers news very
neutrally on my channel
that does kind of mold what you want to
cover
do i want to spend three hours covering
something and then they're like guess
what you're getting paid nothing
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye